reading some podcast fill the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
blue apron blue apron is number one
fresh ingredient in recipe delivery
service in the country their mission is
to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everybody lead last time
you got blue apron how solid was it Oh
delicious Philly cheesesteaks right
we're potato wedges something Philly
cheese sticks with potato wedges it had
a sweet chili stir fry and then the week
before was my favorite because I've
always wanted to learn how to make fried
chicken
I'm a pan-fried chicken I had zucchini
and peppers and the the cool stuff is is
they leave all the recipes online so you
can make it anytime you're on it's great
that's a great deal listen for six weeks
from April 16th through May 21st boy
band has teamed up with Airbnb to bring
you the best home cooking from around
the world each week our menu will
feature recipe developed in
collaboration with Airbnb experienced
host chef Cece a chef from Shanghai who
makes incredible kung pao chicken
a beloved sticky saucy mix of crispy
brown chicken and vegetables listen I'm
getting hungry already check out this
week's menu and get your first three
meals at blue apron comm slash Joey
check out this week's meal menu and get
your first three meals free at blue
apron dock top slash Joey all right blue
apron a better way to cook also listen
how many times I gotta tell you start
you jittery gonna have me up on Twitter
and torment me Joey with me who do I go
ahead and ends right here
Fuji Sports calm domestic Nemec the best
keys especially with the fat [ __ ] if
you're a little [ __ ] you never have
people dangling off here trying to rip
your dollar your [ __ ] sleeve off
Fujiki covers the [ __ ] spread you
understand me tough durable they don't
shrink that much that's all I have is
for Gigi's all right get the superego
it's like a buck 30 but you look like a
doctor you'll feel like a doctor it's
[ __ ] light and you're living you know
I'm saying you're living the life or he
needs an acai bowl you'll be a blue belt
in no time go to Fuji sports.com right
now press in church BAM and get 10% off
your first order delivery right the
house all right not even your first door
I don't care if it's your second
you're foretold I'm gonna give me an
extra 10% all right go to Fuji
sports.com right now press Enter CH
there you go
and they got Muay Thai [ __ ] and [ __ ]
everything you can fly through the air
and take that [ __ ] meal Lee
hey you don't you bad [ __ ] it's
Wednesday it's a beautiful day to be
alive
my main man is here well my main man
Billy Corbin is here my little brother
the [ __ ]
but today I got to christ-killers the
studio I love it
I [ __ ] love to talk to me Billy
Corbin I can't believe I'm actually here
I've only ever done this on the phone
yeah this is well I but I and and this
is like food porn I think my diet is
gonna be me calling you up on the phone
and you're just reading the blue apron
menu to me because I feel I feel
nourished it's delicious delicious yeah
it's like food were take a Scorsese
movie with the food you see the feel
like I'm hungry
[ __ ] roast pork with salsa verde which
sauteed vegetables Easter what stop it
B I'm hungry beef and rice bowl with saw
boiled eggs roasted Brussels no slow or
slower so let's do it slow read it slow
it is beef empanadas with roasted sweet
potatoes and creamy zucchini what are
you [ __ ] crazy sexy son of a fan
Hotel California is that an original LP
original page you know they uh Don
Henley yes
Glenn Frey wrote the lyrics in Miami
Beach the Hotel California hotel
California wrote the lyrics in Miami
Beach 52:42 North Bay Road was a mansion
they rented this is a pretty popular
place Stephen Stills had rented it
before them used to hang out doing drugs
with shel silverstein crazy scene before
that the Watergate burglars and Howard
hunt had rented it before that it was
like a love nest for Howard Hughes and
Ava Gardner back in the day but you know
flash forward and and there they
literally for three days Don Henley and
Glenn Frey closed themselves in like an
upstairs bedroom in this in this cool
creepy old-school Miami Beach mansion
and just the housekeeper would leave
sandwiches and beverages at the door
nobody saw these guys for three days and
they come downstairs think
Henley had like a like a white terry
cloth robe Glenn Frey was in like red
pajamas or so they had just they like
they just hold up there and like Hermits
and they came down with a legal pad and
they said to these two young girls he's
cool like hippie chicks who got in the
business of renting houses to rock stars
who were in town doing music it like
criteria Studios who turned into a big
recording recorded music scene down
there and cus we had the best drugs and
it was away from the the prying eyes and
ears of the record labels and you know
so these guys come down they have this
this legal pad and they say we just
wrote the greatest song we've ever
written and they sat there these two
girls and and God Don Henley and Glenn
Frey and read them line by line kind of
a cappella went through the lyrics so
the first time ever the Hotel California
and and they were they were very proud
of how smart they are and how great the
Lear you know and they like explicate it
like what every line meant and what
every metaphor was and they they just
sat sat there watching this and said
holy [ __ ] that's gonna be a great great
song and I was Hotel California which
was uh lyrics written in in Miami and
recorded and mastered in part at
criteria studios in North Miami Florida
where to this day they got the UM the
upright wooden piano that the Leila
piano solo the famous Layla piano solo
was recorded on um was a great story
about Stephen Stills playing and he had
like a baggie of cocaine on top of it
and he was playing the piano and the
baggie fell over open poof on the on the
keys you know kind of exploded on the
keys and the engineers would go in with
straws and wedge the straws between the
keys for four months later you know
snoring of God knows what's dust cocaine
who the hell knows oh and and this this
is where the magic happened I mean it
was it it was cool those days because
because the I mean you go to criteria
and the Bee Gees would be playing
basketball against crosby Stills Nash
and in the other studio was Aerosmith or
or Fleetwood Mac working on rumors where
they were it was they get rumors they
are in part they dumb Jimmy Buffett did
you know changes in latitudes changes in
attitudes their Margaritaville all
there he was tired of the country music
scene in Nashville his producer said why
don't you sail your sailboat to dinner
Key marina and Coconut Grove more there
live there which is also where David
Crosby and more to sail boat and come to
criteria and that's where he created he
had created the sound he became famous
where that kind of Caribbean rock Sally
did that at criteria the the the Eagles
the Bee Gees never left 461 Ocean the
you know the there are Clapton album he
came rented that house and got the AL
but he named the album after the house
that he rented in Golden Beach for a 61
Ocean the the cover is him standing in
front of this house he gotten out of
rehab great place to go when you're had
to rehab Miami obviously in the
seventies right but he records his how
many called up yet I think he shared a
manager with the Bee Gees and he called
him up and they're like you got to come
to Miami man and the Bee Gees came with
their wives their kids they stated 461
Ocean after Clapton dead and the Bee
Gees never left
they bought three mansions right next to
each other that's the two girls who
rented the Eagles the house in Miami
Beach they they became Realtors and
found the Bee Gees three houses next to
each other in Miami Beach and the Bee
Gees opened a studio called middle ear
they were Tolkien fans like middle-earth
middle ear studios it's now an
enterprise rental car back in sunset
Harbor Miami Beach
the Eagles opened a studio bayshore
studio down in Coconut Grove and it just
was as cool this cool scene but criteria
which is still there it's the Hit
Factory now a lot of magic Aretha
Franklin did respect our ESP ect James
Brown recorded I feel good he recorded
there so it started out like a lot of
R&B in soul and jazz and stuff and then
evolved into into a rock scene I mean
than what they would do is is um so
there was no you had no record labels
anywhere near there you know they were
all out in LA here in New York and so
you had guys and and they would sit he
would criteria would just send the bill
right to the to the studio to the label
rather and say you know just send us the
[ __ ] check you know and they would
get calls from like the accounting
people the record label they'd be like
hey listen I want to ask you about this
cuz they would they would bill for
cocaine under the line-item piano tuning
that's how they would so they would try
to they would try to pass the expense of
the blow on to the record label so the
girl Abel would get the bill from the
studio and be like hey listen we're
trying to figure out we got a bill here
$5,000 for piano tuning and there's only
one ballot on the album what's with all
this what's of all the piano tuning hey
there's one big rock band who came back
years later recorded there in the 80s
came back later in the 90s and the the
studio manager his his mom actually was
a studio manager before him and he said
to the to the lead singer I mean this is
a big big band big frontman he says hey
I don't know if you remember you were
here in the 80s and I was this little
kid running around my mom ran the studio
and now I'm in charge it's great to see
you again the guy says to him I don't
remember a goddamn thing about what
happened here in the 1980s he said I
have one memory about my experience here
recording in the 80s and I only remember
it in part because people reminded me
later about it he said apparently we
were here recording one night we wrapped
up and someone said you got to come to
this lady's house they went to this like
earthy hippy lady's house in North Miami
and he said we sat down on her couch she
came out and put down on the coffee
table a kilo of cocaine an entire kilo
of cocaine she cut it open he says all I
remember is the smell of an entire kilo
of pure you know like 99 hundred percent
pure Colombian cocaine goes that's my
only memory of Miami in the 1980s is
that smell who stole said that shel
silverstein was doing coke you I don't I
don't know if he was doing coke but he
was hanging out at that house poolside
what a weird scene though right like
he's a poet like that's all I know from
killing a five-year-old yeah this is his
man was it we have a good but read that
[ __ ] you had to be a little [ __ ] up to
write to write this [ __ ] that shel
silverstein was writing am I wrong I
mean come on now no you know before the
podcast started were talking I said to
you when are you gonna run for [ __ ]
man and you looked at me I'll never be
may I family no you don't understand you
love the city of Miami just do you even
knowing this
proves even more strengthens my case
that you know everything about Miami I
think that's I don't know I think it's
it's important to be proud of where you
come from I think it's important to rep
something cuz then cuz if you don't if
you read nothing that nothing reps you
you know what I mean it but no no but
here's your beauty you show us the
beauty from time to time you always show
us the ugly [ __ ] like a dog a guy in bed
with a dog giving the dog a [ __ ] hand
job when did this happen
what part of Florida Miami had to be
Miami and and here's the the equally
twisted thing about it or the almost is
twisted thing about it is that it's this
guy in Miami so apparently he's got like
surveillance cameras or something in his
home and he was going through the
footage for some reason and sees his
roommate lying on the bed basically
sexually molesting his dog and turns the
footage over to the to the police that
means the whole thing is the whole
thing's weird like this house is all
wired up you know and and he's watching
his roommate I don't know what to say
about it
ever since I got to LA one thing that I
noticed was Florida in general has a
terrible reputation like I grew up where
I grew up going to Disney World it was
they was like the my favorite place on
earth we'd go every winter my dad lives
in Boynton Beach he loved like it's been
it my entire life is dream has been to
move to Florida as soon as I move out
here everyone everyone looks at Florida
look you're talking about going to jail
or something I don't like why like why
do you have mental if you follow Billy's
Twitter you think you will go to jail if
you follow Billy this days I look like
Jesus Christ I mean it never ends me I
forget it's like the craziest [ __ ] the
one a couple of weeks ago but the cop be
this wife of twice and still being on
the job something [ __ ] just that you
look at and go that can only happen in
Jersey [ __ ] half of my hometown is
mad at me because I posted a corruption
thing they got busted last week why they
mad at you because I pull there was
sterically my buddy posted it first
who's an ex-cop and it didn't even have
a [ __ ] burn on it I usually you have
three likes like like I caught it it was
a midnight and he had posted it like a
thorny afternoon like nobody even like
my hometown is so semi communistic that
nobody had an opinion no and then I pull
on my page I said oh [ __ ] on his so what
you're saying is there's one comment on
his right here's the truth of the matter
I was on the podcast the DJ what we're
talking about the corruption that's in
County
I even got a call from the mayor the
city Brian Stann that he liked me
because I told the truth at least I'm
not making this [ __ ] up but that's what
I'm saying like why can why are people
upset at you for telling the truth
because I didn't say that what happened
was and that same day Allen donated
$50,000 to my grammar school so I put
the telling thing up I said I saw that
one and then I put on the the one about
my corruption and I got the same tomb
like it was like something good to
happen in my hometown today and
something bad happened it just seems
that it what happened was I grew up with
a great family in town that I'm still
dear friends with and who I posted the
story about was their alleged family
member like a brother-in-law and I so
she contacted me and said how could you
post that up little truth I know that I
didn't think about it that way I didn't
know what the [ __ ] I've been gone for 35
years
I don't know nobody's name although
these people are I have no [ __ ] idea
it's a news story - yes oh well I mean
do you ever get stuff like that Billy I
mean it's Jesus do I do I ever
I mean I hear from mayors I hear from
Commissioners I hear from gubernatorial
candidates I hear from certainly police
officers and PIOs and police chiefs and
assistant chiefs and and what have you I
say to you you know I think a lot of
people when they think about it I think
it's mostly when they they think I'm
being unfair about something for the
most part I think people who
who have a brain or half a brain
understand you know they understand that
it's important to aggregate this kind of
news I have a little platform in my
community and and my Billie pulpit as I
like to call it and you know they it's
important to be able to inform people
about what's going on and and and yet
it's definitely a warts-and-all approach
you know it's definitely a you know we
we only roast the ones we love kind of
thing um and Miami Florida in general um
it rarely shocks me but it regularly
disappoints me and I always been
determined I'm a Florida native I'm a
lifelong Miami and and I've always
dreamed of leaving behind a better
Florida than the one I was born into
that dream is swiftly dying you know
along with with my soul but but like I
still there's an I you know as much of a
pessimist as I might appear to be on the
social medium whatever and in in real
life there's still an idealist you know
inside of me that says well [ __ ] if
there's something I can do or say or
tweet or whatever that will help maybe
move the needle a little bit in a
positive direction if only by informing
people of the Florida [ __ ] that that
persists that has become a genre unto
itself and journalism and entertainment
and comedy I think it's I think it's
important I think it's important to
shine a light on your flaws it's the
only way you're ever gonna make anything
better is by saying this is what's
identifying this is what's wrong with it
now if I didn't give a [ __ ] why would I
bother you know I wouldn't I just go and
do my thing I'd make more money if I
just shut the [ __ ] up like you'll work
for these politicians they could pay me
to run campaigns or pay me to you know
to do ads or whatever but I got a
conscience I gotta look myself in the
mirror I got to live with myself I got
to say I got to tell the truth is I it I
got to speak truth to power and I you
know it's it's not that I don't give a
[ __ ] it's that I give I might give too
many shits you know I just I care a lot
about it and I care a lot about the
people and I care a lot about the idea
that you know Miami is a shared
experience where we have self segregated
ourselves you know we've got 34
municipalities in miami-dade County
that means 34 different mayors 34
different
Hall's 34 different police departments
almost I mean everybody's got their own
little fiefdom and we kind of
gerrymandered ourself and and segregated
ourselves by race by religion by
nationality and it's kind of tragic
because you know if you live in you know
aventura you don't give a [ __ ] about
Miami Gardens and if you live in Miami
Gardens you don't give a [ __ ] about
homestead and if you live in Homestead
you don't give a [ __ ] about Sweetwater
in Sweetwater doesn't give a [ __ ] about
highly and highly doesn't give a [ __ ]
about Coconut Grove and so you know
Miami isn't a shared experience anymore
it's become you know I say that's you
know everybody's so selfish in Miami
that's why they call it Miami it's my
[ __ ] a me it's not our a me or your a
me it's it's my [ __ ] a me you know
and and I don't like that I I was hoping
that we got a generation of because you
know people
nobody's ever born in Miami you know
like everybody's like you could be a
Miami for 40 50 60 years you say someone
where you're from they go Jersey Philly
Chicago everybody's from someplace else
but now we have a generation of people
who were born there and who have roots
there you know I got third fourth
generation Cubans and Haitians and
people who were born in hospitals in
Miami in Miami Beach in South Miami and
Kendall and Baptist at you know and and
you you want to inspire a generation to
say well I got roots here now it this
matters to me you know as a lot of our
parents and grandparents not that it
didn't matter to them but it was almost
more of a vacation that's spot for you
know Kay would they wanna be there yeah
there really I don't know it just I I
care a lot I probably care too much I
wish sometimes you know I wish I could I
could care a lot less it's just crazy
that you post a lot of stuff and it's
mainly just corruption I mean the stuff
you point yeah you posted enough of that
to go around a cop shooting Somali
off-duty but basically you do 70 percent
of your action is a cop who have a
mistress a cop with delivered blow you
know I mean it's always something that
people never expect listen when I was 17
years I've found myself in this weird
situation I had lived with this family
after my mom died and I befriended a cop
and he was just young but it was still
1981 and cocaine was starting to [ __ ]
come
and he had a Cosmo song coat and as soon
as he became a cop him and his cousin
couldn't be tightening more so I became
to go between he would give me money in
the daytime in there on midnight when he
got on shift he'd come over to the house
that I give him the cup and Lisa get
that day shift comes up you know and
that's okay I didn't look at him as a
cop I looked at him there's a guy who
grew up it as a brother and then you
know it started to keep going why are
you going back in not here I'm a junior
in high school he said get in the car
come on let's go for a ride and we
started going together and a pack of six
pack of course nips there were six ounce
cans and you need to get a the six of my
camp number right now in northern New
Jersey and until 1:30 we drive over
having a four beers of peace and do four
or five lines of code when he dropped me
off this one for about a month and then
I got to the point where we kept to
eight packs of beer and we each have a
pack a little bottle of blackberry
brandy and we'd sit on this ledge I'm
burning away in a balloon watch people
speed and guess what what they were
doing and the speed would come up on the
thing even if there was speeding he
wouldn't chase him like what's he doing
55 50 - you lost - alive
I give us that time relation but I got
to it a point after I'm one - that that
other cops would meet us and I still
remember passing the coke mirror another
the car next to me there's two guys in
uniforms that's a scene in the [ __ ]
movie but I saw that I saw that if I
tell that story to five to ten people
five times and the question about from
four of those rooms are build a lot of
the stories alive because they've never
seen it and that's what you do you
expose something that people don't see
and guess what they never want to see
because their heads explode and I have
no dog in this fight but what I like
about what Billy does because a lot of
people now with any any online platform
they can tweet whatever they want
Facebook whatever they want and have
nothing to back it up a lot of times you
tweet links to all no no this is what
I'm saying
you really gotta bring receipts yeah you
know I look at the [ __ ] sometimes no
cheese
what if some of it is hilarious you know
crack mother who sold the two kids the
other day you posted a woman a picture a
woman she had it be the ugliest woman
hit with a stick and she did something
she didn't like something like she was
up for eight days and wrong was
something well there was that woman that
was caught with cocaine a baggie of
cocaine or a person she told the draw
the cops that she was driving with the
windows open it was a windy day so the
wind must have blown it the bag her
purse and that because that's not mine
that [ __ ] ain't mine and and she didn't
get away with that they arrested right
away for cocaine possession that was a
pretty popular crazy Florida story that
that week but you know I write every
these days it seems like irony is dead
you know because we have a you know we
have a gangster president like and so
it's and that's not supposed to be how
that works you know in the real world
and it's the same thing here it's like
that irony is is not really dead in
Florida because you have all these
things that are like this public
corruption this backwards I think the
Florida of today is the America of
tomorrow and so if you want to know what
challenges will face or calamities will
befall us as a nation and the years to
come you need only look at the [ __ ]
going on in Florida specifically South
Florida it's just america's canary in
the coalmine
it's just like the bellwether you look
at the trends in crime in politics and
demographics and economics
it all starts in some way or or or
evolves in some way in Florida or Miami
I mean you name it and there is that
Florida connection or that Miami
connection and you know and then we
export this [ __ ] you know no
nationwide it is our greatest
contribution so there's no indigenous
industry in Florida we you know we
produce nothing but oranges and and
assault weapons that's what we
manufacturer produce in Florida and the
other thing we produces is [ __ ] and
fraud and and we're like a Sunshine
State we have an you know we sell the
sunshine we sell a Florida dream we sell
lies that came true because everything
there started is a you know a land fraud
you know land
and grabbed by swampland $20 $20 down
$20 a month till you're ready to retire
and build your dream home and you go
when the [ __ ] can I build a dream home
I'm in the middle of the swamp here
not to mention hurricanes oh yeah my dad
lives there so I was a little nervous
for him I don't know if Miami was in the
path of this last one anyway how do you
stay there when that happens once every
three five yeah you know you know be
better if I were just sitting around
here you know with our thumbs up our
asses and a [ __ ] earthquake or
scariest [ __ ] out here you and you guys
you build your houses on the edge of a
[ __ ] hill with sticks
you got to be I wouldn't how how do you
sleep at night knowing that the ground
will just someday just disappear top
earthquake they're gonna be rolling
those houses slide and there's no listen
we get hurricane watches we have
hurricane warnings we have mandatory
evacuations what happens when earthquake
it's no nap now seven seconds you get
some yeah you have to kiss your ass
good-bye I got just enough time then
smoke a bowl and call it a bowl you
grabbed seven seconds really nope I did
not there's some happy I did something
wrong you know I watched that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] do it on the nose the half
a [ __ ] it was a week new technological
rewards the [ __ ] you got the app puff of
smoke in it and a Joey shaped that hole
in the door he's out of here know how to
download fire but I guess I should get
it in front and as soon as you get that
lower you get the weed the keys to your
car and you pop that gate open so if it
locks in you're not stuck in here just
pop it so the trim will pop that
[ __ ] let's talk about this town
for me because this town makes me sad
like I you know I always say like it's
the you know the the you know cheers
come out of the faucets and like broken
hearts power the grid you know like it's
it's a it this this is a town like
sheer heartbreak and it makes me
profoundly sad whenever I come here for
some reason I don't know like like you
know today I was downtown and I saw a
bus combine there's this ad you know on
the side of the bus it's great began
beautiful woman beautiful woman redhead
and just all done up just just looked
stunning and it was her name and
insurance it's her insurance company
it's an advert with the number on the
side and I thought to myself was that
her dream when she moved out to
Hollywood was that her dream to be on
the side of a looking stunning on the
side of a bus for her Insurance Co did
she say I'm gonna pack up my bags and
head out west and fulfill my my lifelong
childhood dream of getting in the
insurance business I'm like I feel like
everywhere I look is like is like broken
dreams and and broken hearts and it make
I don't know it's it's it's all about
perspective because I remember driving
here I drove here twice and as soon as
you see the palm trees as soon as you
come into California the first time as a
22 year old out of college I was just
like paradise this is this is where my
dreams are gonna come true
this is I don't care about the Beatles
how's it going I mean no I think I'm
very lucky compared to a lot of people
out here who are servers and yeah
working in insurance but it's been when
I first moved to your people always
teased me that I still had a soul like
when I was 22 and then all the people
who were 30 now that I'm almost 30 how
about now
how's your soul ah you had a soul cycle
it's all it's kind of like what Joey was
talking about you just kind of you've
seen it any and you're not surprised
anymore but it still kind of hurts your
feelings when things happen and it's
like the shine kind of wears off like I
could just move to somewhere else and do
this if I wanted to like right now I'm
not going to but it's not it's not the
land of milk and honey like it they make
it seem but I'm driving down visit us
that was saved this cane Boulevard
that's Miami driving up Sunset Boulevard
past the store and whose names on top of
the [ __ ] bill Palmer keeps our life
yeah I mean no god bless yeah I mean
like you're in the 1% baby like I mean
seriously the people who come here and
go someday my name's gonna be good
be atop the the marquee atop the list
you know I'm in the comedy story I mean
it's amazing
I don't know one thing when I came here
I didn't come here with that dream I
came here from the feedback I had gotten
from other comedians I did not come here
with that dream I came out here with a
dream to survive you know what I got the
opportunity Dom a CBS is paying for a
pilot let me take a look I know I don't
let me go check it out if it isn't what
it isn't I packed my bags I go back to
Bald and I start in scratch but what do
I got to lose you know I'm saying like
it was always one of those deals it
wasn't that when she made me a regular
at the store that was hope but nobody
was biting nobody was biting nobody was
really biting nobody really bit until
like Adam Sandler a MADtv then people
bite a little but nothing to stand up
and it's so weird a dear friend of mine
called me 32 shooters do you have a
minute I grew up with this girl she goes
can you talk to me about sag and
non-union how it works and I go what do
you want to know she was on my neighbor
booked the show and I go here's the deal
you have to book one show Union and then
you're eligible that means when you get
the second one sag before you even
celebrate when the end I sneeze the
phone rings from your jet it goes high
and you just you booked it oh my god
congratulations that's gonna be great
you shoot on Wednesday and Thursday
you don't even hang up the phone two
minutes the phone rings ring hi this is
Bill just from sag I have your paperwork
in front of all these military can I
think what time can you come in tomorrow
I come in what are you talking about
coming like what time can you come in
tomorrow for your pre-screening meeting
yeah check your thickness and you're
like 11:30 they're like okay make sure
you have a check and you're like oh
excuse me
check like yeah my sag is $2,500 there
is financing available you're from
Jersey you know about the unions but no
when I first got here was 1250 Oh
when I got double in 1998 it was 1250 to
join I did not have the money the agent
talked to the production company they
put it up Matt Matt the other guy yes
cool [ __ ] descent not the Simpsons
you know bass ketball Oh Trey Parker
Matt Steffey production no [ __ ] that's
awesome is my agent Bluman think these
guys are awesome but I don't know
nothing about like I told my said it's
2,500 does she really want to do this
and she goes why go because you could
just work on Union there right now the
money is in non-union yeah there's no
money in say you booked a Netflix show
you don't get worse Angeles right you go
out you get a buyer you don't get no
recent work for hire yeah they don't
know and and Netflix I find that doesn't
tell you shows numbers oh no no it's
it's it's brilliant it's funny they hide
their phone they don't really go sure it
is it says um it's I think it's amazing
cuz I and I will tell you I'm sorry the
State Department can't keep a secret
there are leaks from the White House
from the NSA from the CIA from the FBI
you never hear there is never a leak at
a Netflix it is rock-solid
you never hear even the faintest trace
of ratings or numbers ever they worship
documentaries oh oh yeah all of them
have been on there or are on there you
know they come and go sometimes I don't
know exactly how all the licensing deals
work but we have tons of [ __ ] on there
and you never know and it's kind of
amazing because what they do is I think
really clever I mean it's obviously a
brilliant business that's why they have
a hundred million subscriber hundred
twenty five I mean incredible incredible
oh yeah million million my only ten
bucks a month for a hundred twenty five
million people it's amazing it's amazing
they're spending billions of dollars on
content which is important for people
like us you know key you know it helps
keep us in business but like you know
what they do is pretty clever because
you know they're about to let's say
debut a season of a show you got ten
episodes right ten hours they want you
to dedicate of your life to binging this
[ __ ] you know right you know and so they
do something brilliant usually the week
of the premiere of a season like the
days leading up to it you know I'm
flicking the switch and it's gonna be
online in 60 70 countries
they announce that it's been picked up
for another season meaning it signals to
the audience that if you invest your
time there'll be another you know
another series another season at the end
of you know at the end of the tunnel
here next year or whatever and it also
gets the talent less concerned about the
ratings because the only thing you care
about in ratings is are we gonna get
another season are we gonna work again
are we gonna get picked up so if you
know you're getting picked up before the
season even premieres then you know you
don't even ask questions because that's
all you the only thing you matter the
only thing matters with ratings is you
get you know I always say the measure of
a successful filmmaker is not ratings
it's not Awards it's not money or box
office it's do you get to work again and
if you get to work again in this
business you are a sucess
that's it that you broke it down you are
a success
cuz listen some people make good movies
some people make bad movies but there's
a market for bad movies people love to
see bad people make bad movies and they
keep giving - and you sit there at home
going hot at this [ __ ] guy because
there's an audience there's a god bless
them I don't I don't I don't knock and I
don't knock another person's hustle you
know we've all we've all got our you
know our business and and some people
like what we do some people don't like
what we do but if there's an audience
for it you know you'll hopefully get a
chance to do it again and that's all
that that's all that matters we were
talking about what what do you do when
you get there Billy wants to be a
director of Bolton becomes a director he
direct kind of called Cowboys now you're
there yeah now you're there you can you
know what you got now everybody's
watching for the second you got to keep
you oh but it's true what you gotta do
now everybody's waiting for the second
one that's why the second down in music
is so important yeah we made it and we
made a shitty sequel that's why it's
same the second out gotta be a
[ __ ]
you've been working on the first one all
your life yeah that first project you've
been working on all your life so now I
put pressure on you to do it you didn't
do it but do it in two years that's what
people don't really [ __ ] them now you
know and what are you left with you let
you put it all on it you put it all out
there on the first one now you got
[ __ ] b-sides from the first one and
now you're trying to get inspired
and you're a totally different person in
a totally different station and life
you've got you know I always say I call
it spotlight syndrome you know I believe
that no people would say why are like
you know child actors end up so screwed
up or people you know what's with Kanye
you know etc you know that's what's with
what's with Kim's husband uh you know so
yeah I called spotlights I believe that
um or Superman's syndrome really is what
it is spotlight syndrome is when you
become not famous anymore
Superman syndrome is you know you're
you're told how great you are at
something happens to athletes you know
who eventually go broke or movie stars
or music artists you told your whole
life how brilliant you are and how great
you are and you know people telling you
yes yes yes yes yes and you know there's
a saying you know they're saying it's
it's it's it's a theory with them
alcoholics or drug addicts um that you
are emotionally stunted your development
your emotional development is stunted at
the age you start using I believe the
same thing is true for famous people
like really famous people so you wonder
why famous people people who become
really famous really young when you stop
hearing no you know when you when people
stop telling you the truth about [ __ ]
when people are just around you to to
you know to to kind of leech on and and
and ride your you know your wave of
success you're not gonna be able to kind
of develop as a normal person at that
point and it's same thing you're right
but like the second album it's like
we'll wait
now we're famous now we're rich now
everybody says we're geniuses what the
do we do now I think a lot of people go
mad a lot of people go crazy I was here
for the video book 2004 2003 spent two
million dollars on a video when people
were youtubing like oh you tube you
tobin herb is making these videos and
you get a video that did you know five
hundred thousand and three days you're
like okay and people are now waiting for
your second one I totally that I can't
tell you how many college kids come out
here super confused they've gotten to
college and whatever frat they belong
till they watch sign that live on the
salius doesn't going on getting [ __ ]
they sit there like hate [ __ ] idiots
and they
get that [ __ ] horror show with his
comedy which is supposed to be American
comedy it's just garbage and they come
out here with a credit card from dad and
they joined I saw the building last
night for the set against it
Citizens Brigade whatever on Sunset yeah
they have two of them in LA now thousand
[ __ ] month oh right there
I think they keep the lights on sucker
soup suckers suckers come into anything
you could train your way to comedy or
take improv they've been doing it for
years
you know just they just don't get it
whatever they come out here and they
join they go through that whole system
and they buy into it they buy into what
those people say listen I did I did six
weeks of an acting class and I worked
with a famous actor it was quit acting
class you have great instincts done
James Kohlberg tell me stumble acting
class you got you ready and sticks don't
let them ruin your instincts kid don't
just ruin them yeah you know does it
does it how do i bought the steam for a
while but then i moved away from it when
we're talking about fame to think I hate
about fame is the Kardashians are [ __ ]
up you know if you want to talk about
selling your soul one thing I've been
here is 20 years I've never sold my soul
I can look you in the eye as a man as a
Jewish man as a man of faith graduation
and part time whatever it serves me
right yeah I start dancing the whole
thing I eat the white fish I tell them
how good it tastes I love that bread you
know I'm saying you show up at a Barbra
Streisand Constance in the first row
that's a Jew I'm saying you wanna you
wanna go developmental Brahma Streisand
she a month to change are you doing all
right vote for me
shabbat shalom oh you don't worry about
who am i the question is who are you and
how we're gonna work this do you wanna
sell movies and Kansan at the Hollywood
Bowl what you see is what Wonderworld us
up one of her 18th farewell tour yeah
[ __ ] thing you wanna be known this
town you always be a time with acting
click spend the 3G and sit up in front
with all the rich
Jews in Hollywood because they can't
there was that famous back in the day it
was AAA or Narconon yeah that's what the
deals were getting now they're getting
done a Barbra Streisand another Barbra
Streisand concert with a head shot home
with a [ __ ] three picture deal a
[ __ ] eight series order nobody knows
this [ __ ] there's somebody right now
listening was gonna go to Barbra
Streisand no he's gonna go in Idaho
that's where you [ __ ] up
there's no Jews in Idaho you gotta go to
the Hollywood ball or the forum or
whatever they just redid it just make
just walk in like oh my god I'm so
confused where do I sit who's this
[ __ ] Gentile [ __ ] well
speaking of Netflix I mean I always
loved documentaries Billy I I don't know
I I just always found them very
interesting but has Netflix really made
them explode because like I'll be on
Netflix just scrolling through and I'll
see I'll just scroll through the
documentaries and see what looks good
like I didn't really think documentaries
had that big of a platform before
everything on Netflix makes it more
accessible and then helps to I think
enlarge the audience for it I mean that
you know and when we first made cocaine
Cowboys you know it was interesting we
started to discover a market for
nonfiction film amongst the demographic
that was not traditionally thought of by
documentary filmmakers and distributors
as the the normal you know it was
audience for documentary so it was
younger it was more urban you know there
was a big hip-hop contingent that
embraced cocaine Cowboys and really
helped blow it up in the bootleg market
and by name checking name checking it in
lyrics and songs and and you know and
and our discovery was that talking with
artists with hip-hop artists they were
like well of course we love
documentaries we're all about keeping it
real you know what is what is you know
uh the UM Public Enemy used to call Cha
they used to call rap music CNN for
black people so Chuck D said you know
and so
rap music is all about keeping it real
and all in rap you were some of the best
rap songs or documentaries you know are
true stories you know that rhyme and are
set to a beat and so what was incredible
about that is that we were credited in
part for introducing a kind of a
different audience to nonfiction film
and then from there I mean in the last
10 years 12 years since cocaine Cowboys
came out everything is gone nonfiction
you know I mean everything yeah doc
miniseries you got him on [ __ ]
billboards out here on Sunset Boulevard
Universal a documentary series or a
nonfiction series you know being
advertised in that way before but the
whole thing blew up and I think Netflix
and the streaming service has been
extremely influential in that and all
the streaming services you have Hulu now
you have Amazon every that competition
helps generate more work and and and
more revenue in the marketplace and and
people can just sit down and with their
phones or the laptops or whatever Apple
TVs and go what's on I can watch
anything I want you know it's like
people talk about the music do all the
music recorded music business is dead
but now more people than ever are
listening to more music than they'd ever
have in their lives I mean you got a
stack of LPS over here this used to be
how you'd listen to music you know other
than the trend you know then the radio
now you go to Spotify you can listen to
all the music and all the music you want
all day long it's the same thing with
movies now you have access to [ __ ] you'd
never be able to see and that's when the
the niche stuff starts to to catch on
and people realize oh there's an
audience for all this stuff that you
know that we never really knew about
before because no one really no one no
one really could could get it before now
you can get documentaries everywhere and
people realize oh [ __ ] people love
people love keeping it real people love
you know truth is stranger than fiction
I love a documentary what I learned
something I even like a documentary more
when I learned some but I already know I
can like when you did the one about the
brook oh yeah athletes going broke broke
when you did broke like that [ __ ]
open my eyes but my eyes will already
open it doesn't take a genius to know
that you take a 21 year old kid you want
a 7 million in sign
bonus at eleven million dollars either
he's not gonna go crazy if you put in a
computer and stats that that just the
statistics are [ __ ] mind-boggling how
many people do anything with that money
that money gets chopped up soon as it
gets there you know I was thinking about
Whitney Houston yet that we were here me
and endeavor really they doing a podcast
about top selling arms I told my wife I
didn't know meatloaf was the number four
selling album of all time I'd had a hell
I didn't know back in black was number
two better salad selling out well if you
look at the top 20 best song I was like
wouldn't he use that way through your
mom and I'm sitting in a are they going
who's chopping up her [ __ ] money now
cuz she died the daughter died yeah you
know you know how many [ __ ] brothers
to sitting around every month we waitin
for the first [ __ ] that Whitney money
comes in [ __ ]
I'm just think about what that would
Prince you know they released his new
song and now they got a new album coming
out in September of all this stuff that
he had recorded that he probably never
planned on anybody ever hearing and yes
you know estates estates are a whole
business people run estates yeah Bruce
Lee Elvis oh yeah you know make a lot of
money Michael Jackson Michael jelly yeah
Michael Jackson made more money dead did
he did alive and that's crazy guys can't
take it with you but at least with music
you can continue to make a living for
your whole life
the one in broke that really got me
because I he I grew up he was my first
like Celtics the person I was a fan of
Paul Pierce and Antoine Walker and
Antoine Walker gambled and drank his way
to a hundred million dollars and he's
brought like zero like it just gets
crazy and then you can't buy 35 you're
just you physically can't play yeah
you've got what listen you think about
you know the the way it used to be when
the American Dream was alive and well
spoiler alert it ain't no more but when
the American Dream was a thing you know
the way it would work in the world the
average American you know you you go to
school you graduate you get a job maybe
a you try a couple different rackets you
know along the way to see what you're
what you're good at or what you get into
and then you find a business that you're
involved you know you're involved you
work your way up and as you work your
way up
you're getting promotions hopefully
you're getting a raise you know as
you're working your way up the food
chain you're making more money along the
way you do some things maybe you get
married maybe you get divorced maybe you
buy a house maybe you lose a house you
make some good investments make some but
you start to learn as you go you know
experience wisdom and all come and as
you grow and then you you reach your 50s
you know and you're making the most
money hopefully you've ever made in your
life because you've worked your way up
in something sixties you know go on your
retire and take that and turn that [ __ ]
upside down
and that's what it's like for an athlete
you as you said you're 21 22 years old
barely in some cases someone gives you a
multi-million dollar signing bonus pile
of cash you know and you're only paid if
you're a football player only paid
during the season so you have to figure
out how to make that you know how to
make that last you know um and now what
you're gonna make that money maybe from
what 21 the average career in the NFL is
three point three seasons that's it and
NFL has the shortest careers the highest
the lowest average salaries the highest
rate of career-ending injuries and most
of the players are journeyman you know
they're making League minimum which
might sound like a lot of money you know
seven hundred ran or whatever it is you
know to anybody else but when you're in
that line of work you don't know where
you're gonna be or if you're gonna have
a job the next day or if someone's gonna
say yo you just got traded you got to
move across the country sell your house
take your family at it your take your
kids out of school move it it's a pain
and yet you know like it's between that
and healthcare and everything it really
SAP your uh your resources but and then
before you're 30 years old it's over
you're done with the only thing you've
ever known how to do the only thing
you've ever trained to do the only thing
anyone's ever told you you're any good
at it's over you're retired before
you're 30 and there is zero percent
chance that you're ever gonna make that
kind of money again doing anything else
let alone figuring out what the hell
you're gonna do every guy say oh I'm
gonna do a radio show I'm gonna go I'm
gonna become a broadcaster or go on NFL
Network well first of all you think
about the number of jobs that are
available in that the odds are you're
not gonna have an opportunity to do that
and then when you look at the salaries
and media there's not that's that's not
the kind of money that you were
accustomed to making through your 20s
you know and then these guys are at home
all the time
they used to be on the road or here or
there they're at home with a wife they
never really really knew kids they don't
really know and then that strip puts a
strain on the marriage and next thing
you know 50% of your net worth he's gone
to your ex-wife and you're you know and
you're fat and you're your child support
I mean it's it's a really it's like you
said it's like these things it's so
obvious it's right there in front of you
and then you see it synthesized like
that and you're like this is just sad
and it's just sad you know I have a path
I could work every week you don't get
out of my wife the daughter's hair run
my life out there and at 30 I would have
done that right now I would have been
working for weeks or months giving a
[ __ ] coming home on Tuesday now at this
age I appreciate the life so much that I
am only out two weeks a month don't give
a [ __ ] who calls what don't be there
next year if I cannot take a red-eye
this week I would like to not take a
[ __ ] red eye this week I'm too old
for the redeye van I think I took the
red-eye a couple of weeks ago lumbus I
did okay really that was okay you never
animal dump your downloaded [ __ ] to
watch on my iPads you know you have to
you don't like a pro I'm not a problem
I'm an amateur very that's all flying is
flying is the hardest thing about flying
is security yes pain in the ass all that
other [ __ ] getting to a plane getting on
and now you're on the plane five hours
seems like an eternity
now if you got three episodes of narcos
download it that's three hours you're
gonna read a book I got an iPod
I'm oh isn't some music for now should I
haven't listened to in a while let's to
spin it see what happens you know I'm
saying it's preparation you're well for
preparation yes well you have a little
hotel pad I steal from every hotel and I
have a bunch of my sleep apnea bag and I
got one pen in there
xanax I got an edible I got a vapor pen
the only thing it makes me sad about
that is that that means there are there
are two weeks out of the month where you
are depriving people in some city or
some some club or something out there
some theatre of you of the experience of
seeing you live which I tell everybody
who has a chance to do is to see you
live I love all that [ __ ] I love
performing but I also know what my
breaking point at this age at 25 and 26
and 32 you really don't know your
breaking point and then one day you call
your agent go cancellous I can't do this
no more I know my breaking point my
breaking point the third week in a row
is when I don't want to come out and
take pictures it's when I can't wait to
get this [ __ ] set over I get sick and
try the saying this [ __ ] joke that's
not good when that goes nuts I'll start
going into your head it's time to go
home yeah I mean I'd rather give you a
fresh weekend of fresh fresh the legs of
fresh I'm rested during the week that
wrote three new jokes I'm gonna try them
out that's when you want to see me I'm
55 if I was 38 I could do three good
weeks a month do two back-to-back take
one off and then do a two-day can't do
it well bit wish I could but Billy how
many projects do you have going out like
at one time usually six seven eight Wow
so yeah so it's a big slate well you
have to because you know Ghana the days
of the one hit one of living off the fat
of the land you can't just do a
Margaritaville anymore and parlay that
into a lifetime of it's unfortunate it's
amazing you can't do that anymore I mean
you know it's all about the next gig
it's the next podcast is the next you
know movie it's the next TV show it's
the next spot it's the next gig and
that's what it is it's a you know it's a
gig economy and and and we have to keep
we have to keep working I think you got
a work when the work is there because
someday the work is not gonna be there
and that's the day that kills me like I
always say I turn it down that day is
never gonna come again but now I have to
be in here for 20 years
I could already tell where you go with
this like I've heard every story you
take me out to lunch you tell me scale
tell me don't have a distribution
it's on the way law talk to these
Chinese people on new york and next
thing you know you shoot your heart out
you you would learn the lines you you do
more beyond the ropes than what you get
paid for and you get a call three months
that do you serve that friend NBC and
you're like what happened to your
Chinese cousin oh well hey every leg
today they think they quit that company
and now that thing you worked out as I'm
[ __ ] you to because you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I need a fan like I seen this
from the jump you know so I feel the
same you know a city lament wrote a book
called making movies and city Lynette
has a ridiculous
ridiculously prolific career you look at
his film a your IMDB the guy directly
like 753 movie like it's ruined it's
ridiculous he directed me in Bronx Tale
it's a silly a little bit yeah yes I am
two million dollars to do the end but
CBS's answer my PD bull oh really oh
that doesn't spray was in New York I
mean New York ago June 99 Sydney act no
I don't think so yeah but he uh he wrote
this book and he basically said every
time someone gave me an opportunity to
direct a movie I said yes be caught for
several reasons not the least of which
you don't know when those calls are
gonna stop coming number one for him it
never did he directed till the day he
died god bless him and was doing some of
his best work at the end too but he and
the other thing he said was I got better
at it because every time you know every
projects new so you learn something new
on every project you work on but that's
the thing for I really like I'm when
people like stop me it's weird in Miami
especially like people will stop me and
be like are you Billy Corbin and I'll go
are you a process server they'll say no
I'll be like then yes yes I am
and you gotta have a line you know that
that makes them laugh you know and and
they'll go i'll dude you know I know
you're probably sick of hearing this and
I'll be like are you gonna tell me that
you love my work like yeah I love
cooking I'm like why would I
ever get sick of hearing that like what
a great thing that is if someone wants
to come up to you and a stranger on the
street and tell you that they love what
you do I mean what a great what an honor
that is well I will never get tired of
hearing that you know I think that's and
who knows how much longer in life you
know Mike my grandfather you know it was
sort of the patriarch of our of our
family very successful in his time you
know one of the things he said because
that's one of the toughest things about
getting older is becoming irrelevant you
know he's like you he goes he ran a
company he mattered to thousands of
people that he you know employed he
mattered to you know it still matters to
his family of course but everything kind
of revolves around you you know then
people grow up and your grandkids have
great kids and every you know you can
goes and you just become a little less
involved with the world day-to-day and
the phone stops ringing you know like it
there's not as much action you don't
matter as much to as many people and and
it's hard you know to kind of make that
adjustment so I love being being busy
I love out having someplace to go and
and work to do and but I'm also
developing in my late 30s this new thing
which is I think your thing which is you
know I'd much rather be home with my
family tonight like I love that I've
never liked to be home this you know I
like I like being in Miami I like but
I'm starting to find like at this age
it's like I'm 39 now and I'm like you
know I'd love to do tonight not go out
and drink with friends get home from the
office as quickly as possible and hang
out with my family and and I love that
when that turns into a good time like
you said you don't want to leave two
weeks at it you know I added a month you
know I think that's great I think I'm
probably getting there too like that's
why with our projects Julie I you know I
I I'm I would say like oh I'll take on
as many projects as possible if they're
Miami projects or Florida projects where
our offices in Miami Beach I don't gotta
go nowhere you know like every once in a
while you got to do a little you got to
come out here do the song and dance you
know the racket you know we're out here
pitching and selling and selling and
pitching and you know you got to put
your tap shoes on you know got it got to
get up on the desk and shuffle step
shuffle step flap heel flap heel flap
heel step you know wave the the top hat
and the cane around but other than that
if I can be at home I mean I love that
I got three different things number one
I was married once with a child the
daughter and I lost it I lost that
relationship so number one now number
two now I have to work harder hmm
you know years ago when Ralph he first
got hot you know I would call him to
thing what a [ __ ] are you and he do him
tapia how to do prayers for next week or
whatever the [ __ ] you would save in real
evidence and there's wet Wednesday
Tuesdays and Thursdays I gotta stop what
I'm doing at 4:15 meet my wife at the
house I'm gonna go pick up my daughter
we go to ballet or swimming and between
you and I sometimes I just sit there and
stare at my daughter in the pool advance
and I just drift off my mind just drove
off you know I left the 15 minutes I get
to school there's a little voice inside
of me that knows what the [ __ ] are you
doing here and then I got another voice
that comes in and go if I could wake
Ralphie up right now I would ask him but
would you rather be in Tempe on a
Tuesday or watching his daughter [ __ ]
swimming how will he do it this time
you know that's what I think about so to
me money comes and goes
money comes and goes in this life for me
I was never relevant in my 30s or in my
40s I just constantly worked now for the
first time one of my 50s I'm selling
tickets is [ __ ] like that so I got
nowhere to go
like this just do I'm saying like for me
it's completely different like I got so
many hats in the ring right now you know
whether it's the produce you know
whether it's the podcast whether it's
writing the book whether it's writing in
the journal for my daughter
I don't end all day like it doesn't end
it's it's I love people who think that
you get to a certain level and managers
and agents and assistants I wouldn't
[ __ ] him on the system if he paid me cuz
he can't do what I could do I know the
damage I could do I know the damage I do
you know I get up on Monday morning at
5:15 you're done by the time you get to
your office it not happy about telling
you
to do today exactly to the T so there's
no misunderstandings you know and that's
the way I've always been I'm big on
Monday mornings and nobody sells you
like you do nobody who's gonna get you
work you got ya know and once people get
that idea that concept you know I've
seen so many people come out here I got
the best agents now when do you go down
there's no such thing you got you gotta
go down at the agency if you have a
theatrical agent for example what I did
when I was a theatrical client like I
still do it is I'm there every three
weeks another fuse yeah
no headshots resume yeah knock yourself
up in the queue got on there been a true
cake thank you some brownies don't share
them with the kids
I saw the CA I showed up with [ __ ]
yum yum donuts 36 Mexican deep-fried
[ __ ] dollars for white people in
Beverly though those [ __ ] went
bananas sometimes I show up with a bag
Hannibal's every assistant gets an
edible every agent gets an edible for
their husband or wives or whatever you
know I never show up empty-handed but
you show up what's the purpose of it joy
so they see you yeah so you're in their
[ __ ] mind
I love I've seen people come and go in
this town I've said me I wasn't less
than me took him to lunch
well I didn't know was likely to go to a
strip club the first thing you do when
the agents take him to a strip club
because now you see his braunability's
now you see if he's a [ __ ] pig or a
gentleman if he comes back he and his
ties loose and his cheeks are red and
he's leaking from his nose covered in
covered in blood
chilly pull the car around pull the car
around pop the trunk that's the agent I
know what I'm saying that's the guy I
want I don't want the guy that says you
know she touched my dick and I almost
had a heart attack I'm gonna call Jack
I'm gonna call Terry Crews someone was
someone once told me they said but they
say they said uh agents are like cell
phone companies they all suck they just
this there's never one bet I wanted I
want to tell you this I don't know if I
ever told you I never I don't know that
ever said it publicly so for hurricane
Irma last year last September
I was in a mandatory evacuation area
meaning we had no choice we had to
boogie
pull ugh one-year-old daughter I mean
what are we gonna do we gotta get we got
it I mean if it was just me alone or my
wife I we probably would have just
stayed quick you got him in the hell you
gotta get the hell out of here so
although some dry roads where are we
gonna go I said let's go to Nashville so
we flee to Nashville for hurricane Ouma
last September and I hit up Ralphie and
I say we're fleeing higher ground coming
to Tennessee coming in Nashville and
Ralphie says you're staying at my house
I'm like Ralphie there's no I'd already
gotten an air B&B I'm like rau I already
paid you know I'm like Ralphie I'm not
seagulls I got a five-bedroom it's all
childproof for my kids like bring your
mother-in-law your wife your baby you're
all stunned like router or not I'm like
I'll see ya every day I can while I'm
there I'm like I'm not God but that's
the kind of guy that he was he was
inviting it was just unbelievable and
then we had plans every day and he
wasn't feeling good every day we're
gonna do brunch we do this and he just
wasn't feeling good but he did his
Tuesday gig
he did his Tuesday gig at that club at
that local club I think Bailey's zany's
I think you know I think here a monthly
show there yeah and it was like he
didn't want to let the the locals that
you know you didn't want to let the
hometown crowd down and we go to see it
and it's just typical like just holding
court you know for hours an hour and
just some of the best crowd work I ever
saw anybody do it was funny it was dirty
it was sweet some of it was sweet so
there was some FSU students sitting in
front who had fled for the hurricane who
he bought there you know he bought their
drinks he was just like he was just you
come out with us tonight we're going now
and take out tonight on the town you
know you're you're a hurricane refugee
they just driven in that night the girl
was falling asleep and he was just it
was just on I went backstage to see him
and and he wasn't feeling good you know
and he says you got to come out with us
you got to come out and drink with us my
wife said please don't he doesn't he
looks like [ __ ] you know I'm afraid
you're gonna catch something and then
we're square cooped up in this Airbnb
apartment I want the baby to get sick
while we're you know
refugees here and there and so I didn't
go I didn't go with him that night and
he wasn't well enough again to come and
you know to come out after that and we
went home and I don't know what was it
we cleared two weeks later not even I'm
on a plane and with internet and I got
the and I just sat there crying I just
set it on the plane crying and crying
it's like the last thing was like you
come to my how do you stay with me you
stay with me this guy it's the biggest
heart it's the biggest heart I miss him
like crazy something crazy the biggest
was shoutouts real quick
Paul Denver I love you [ __ ] Pat
Kosta Shane see I'm the most pop mop
full metal Pete vassilis a Demopoulos
made a little Greek buddy Pat Shea I'll
see you in Tempe Freddy doll and Ross
Vincent
don't forget Tempe tomorrow night
[ __ ] when I [ __ ] around
and then whatever they 18th I think I'm
in Providence and that's all that but
then I'm in the stress factory so get
your tickets now but I'll see you
[ __ ] tomorrow night in Tempe
bring the reefer everything whatever you
guys the house grandmother's chemo
tablets whatever the [ __ ] you got I want
I'm saying I'm in the mood I'm in the
mood for a melody I'm gonna mood in the
melody I'm gonna move I tell people your
story I told you this before I better
but I it's it's important it's important
to reiterate it's like a comedy
bucket-list thing for me I tell people
I'm like if you have not seen Joey do
the story about doing blow with his cat
live you have to like it's a thing that
like it like to me it's like a legendary
thing that like people have to explain I
thought like I experienced something
that was like special and you know
because it's not just comedy it's like
it's theater it's monologuing it's like
it's it's a special it's a special thing
like for me I only got salt once only
saw you do that once but it was it was
it's special it's like I lit I called my
comedy bucket list thing it's like boom
I did that I did that that's amazing
now I have a great time especially with
the story tone now you have a new thing
coming out with the cocaine Cowboys yeah
because if it ain't broke don't fix it
what I say you know I'm not I'm not huh
not a one-hit
but I may be a one-trick pony let's just
be real about this but now we got a new
a new cocaine Cowboys documentary this
is interesting people don't know this
when we first started cocaine Cowboys it
was supposed to be about Willy Falcone
and Salma gluta they were known as the
boys los muchachos they were local
heroes in the Miami Cuban community they
were the biggest cocaine traffickers at
that time that's certainly the biggest
Cubans because this was about 79 to 89
right in the entire the other decade was
really they were the cocaine Cowboys for
us and and my producing partner Alfred
Spellman his best friend's dad was an
attorney who was working on the case
so they used to ride carpool while his
dad if you can picture for a moment Sean
Penn in Carlito's Way yeah like this
type of got you know yelling on the cell
phone the old school you know
speakerphone and the cut you know about
this case and and so that was middle
school and then high school they were
tried in 95 96 then there was a second
trial in Oh 100 102 so high school
college for us was Willie and Sal the
boys like this case the Miami Herald
when they would do headlines about these
guys or the case it would say Willie and
Sal acquitted Willie and Sal charged but
just their first names dude that's what
I would say in the Miami Herald and we
just say Willie and Sal this Willie and
Sal that they just knew them by the
first names I mean just Miami knew them
and it was an incredible story of public
corruption of in addition to the you
know the normal cocaine trafficking type
stuff but this was but when we started
making cocaine Cowboys we wanted to do
this story in like you know oh five oh
four it just wasn't ripe yet you know
the trial had just ended no there wasn't
people who could talk it was federal
court so there wasn't a lot of access
you know like there isn't a state court
and we just couldn't do it
so we bit some cocaine Cowboys believe
it or not was Plan B that was our back
out plan was cocaine you know the way we
made cocaine Cowboys it was supposed to
be about this and then through the years
as a labor of love people would reach
out to us hey you want to hear my story
about Willie and south and we would stir
the years who would just start on speck
we would just shoot an interview
you know US Attorney defense attorney
one of the one of the co-defendants who
were smugglers with these guys and we
just started to just start to build this
movie over
like seven or eight years and it's six
hours long it's called cocaine Cowboys
los muchachos it's a six-hour document
e-series all about these guys I think
it's better than then cocaine Cowboys
been in the original it was what the
first one was supposed is about it's six
hours you'll hopefully hopefully you'll
get to binge it you might need some you
might need some to to to get through it
but no but it's it moves super fast like
Cowboys does in a plane yeah I watch
those on the plane they're nice long
flight yeah yeah you wanna watch a movie
I can't sit yeah I know
you know what your phone doubling for
three days go to an afternoon matinee
that's what everybody wants to talk we
want to call you about something I got
gigs you want a break they got a movie
for you jump out of a helicopter every
day you know you got a movie being at
1:00 Monday and Tuesday nobody'll call
Wednesday as soon as I sit up
I'm not even biting the first [ __ ]
popcorn the phone starts right grudge
match was on the other night I was just
on TV I guess a couple weeks ago
whatever I said I was and there you are
reading in Us Weekly and I'm just
laughing my ass off
I mean you make me laugh sit and read
and go [ __ ] Us Weekly magazine that's
it that's all it took I just started I
just are laughing my assets I love Lana
wait night on TBS yeah a lot I feel yeah
wow that's a that's a movie that should
not have worked that is great
like I went in thinking like oh this
could be a mess and it was hilarious it
was a really good one it was a good
movie at all it turned out really well
dude it turned out well I just pissed me
off because the public didn't buy it
like I bought it I bought it for once I
finally know this is gonna be a good
movie somebody interesting is gonna win
the box office
a two bag of dicks came out Christmas
Day me and leave away two [ __ ] we
went to Christmas Day with a bunch of
people from the church or something like
that yeah my Christmas week yeah we went
out and saw that Lindley yeah we saw it
lemonway 30th anybody was there yeah the
church and we had a good little time you
know and that was the best part about it
wasn't the premiere it was that little
thing we did with like 30 guys we just
says show up let's watch the movie
together not everything is a hit out of
the gate but when you see the way they
the replay value on that man people
because because people love it because
when it's it's one of those movies
that's when it's when it's
you'll just sit and watch it it's just
likable it's just watchable just
watching those guys do their thing in a
story that should be totally ridiculous
but somehow they sell it some that I
sell it and they buy it and I don't know
like it's just it's just one it's not a
masterpiece don't get me wrong but it's
just a movie that it's a simple movie
with a great cast that just works and
and and as it is fun to watch so why not
watch it all the damn time and I do I
find it every time I flip through the
channels and it's on I find myself
sitting there watch it was a fun movie
for me to shoot like I was only there
three days you know I think I was in New
Orleans for six days because I had two
days off so I just did comedy and booked
a local little gig I just did comedy
they put me up at this hotel it's so
weird how your uh it wasn't that I don't
want to say prejudice but you programmed
a certain way well I checked them they
go by the way we have a restaurant here
and breakfast is at 6:00 lunches at
12:00 and dinner is it 6:00 or something
like oh what are you talking about oh
just coming in no feed you really and I
go what do they have do they have like a
menu they go no it's whatever they cook
like ok now went down in the morning and
it was either oatmeal or you know have
fruit and cereal but the [ __ ] lunch
that's what I weigh and I hate every
meal like I wasn't happy that every
[ __ ] meal they had was one better
than the other really they only had 60
people at the hotel was a tiny hotel a
couple of movie a couple of the actors
were there and they just served whatever
was on the menu I get one of those
things like there's no menu like tonight
is steak with potatoes but just the best
steak and potatoes one that I went down
they had pork chop one that I went down
and I made a meatloaf
like all Cajun style was [ __ ] it was
brilliant
I would have never eaten there at all I
think that I didn't I think it was one
meal underneath there other six days I
want to stay in this place yeah I don't
know dick sounds great
when does this come out the six hour
movie that's a good question well that's
what we're here to find out
alright so we're in LA for you know so
hopefully I'll have I'll have more news
on it but it's it's looking great we're
really proud of it we really
our asses off we basically finance the
thing you know on our own through the
years you know you work on a project he
gets some fees kind of reinvest it if
you will you know and to carry this
thing because it wasn't it something we
could just do in one fell swoop it was
like when people became available got
out of prison we're willing to sit down
and you know go on camera we would just
grab the inner you know we just grab the
interview so we could we could kind of
accumulate this this content and it's
just it's just wild it's just it's
because it's like the trials or the
cocaine Cowboys these guys in their
first trial they spent twenty four
million dollars cash on their defense
so forget OJ these guys had a dream team
they they had John Gotti's lawyer they
had Roy black they had you know Al
Krieger they had a dream team like you
could not believe and they had an army
of paralegals because these guys were
put in solitary confinement because they
knew everybody in town everybody Salma
gluta was like The Godfather the Cuban
you know I will eat that would come and
say I can't make my rent he'd hand her a
stack of cash say pay rent for the year
pay your mortgage you come my daughter
got into University of Miami but I can't
afford the tuition here's the - here's
the money like he was that kind of
figure and he was beloved he bought a
lot of loyalty and a lot of friends in
you know little havana Hialeah
you know Sweetwater those predominantly
Cuban communities exile communities and
it's like a Cuban crime saga you know
his father was indicted his his son was
indicted and they twenty-four million
dollars these paralegals I was like so
they're in solitary confinement cuz they
don't want them corrupt they kept
getting caught with cellphones and you
know various things that you're not a
contraband and whatever so they that
that means they you know didn't have any
contact with the outside world but to
prepare for trial you're allowed to sit
with your attorneys all day long right
so they pay these women who would go to
paralegal school or whatever the hell
you need to get your certification or
whatever and these women would be paid
to come to the prison pull them out of
the cell of the cell for six seven eight
nine out all day if necessary they could
talk on the phone they would eat lobster
or whatever they brought in spoiler
alert
one of the paralegals gets pregnant if
you can believe that just
one just just one that we know that we
know of gets pregnant I mean these guys
had some pretty insane adventures and
then it comes down to this this is the
most expensive prosecution in the
history drug prosecution in the history
of the feds this was a 75 tons of
cocaine was the indictment and over two
and a half billion dollars is what is
what they estimated the they
conservatively estimated the operation
at and these guys were also world
champion offshore powerboat racers
this is classic Miami Vice [ __ ] and the
go-fast cigarette boats in the Don Z's
and everything these guys are out there
on ESPN on USA Network live on TV
they're there internationally recognized
champion sportsman okay and smuggling
seventy five tons modestly modestly of
cocaine how do they know Sal kept
Ledger's he kept Ledger's of every kilo
of every dime of every dollar so that's
how they were able to put this case
together
um what winds up happening is it comes
down to it they have twenty they've like
twenty six cooperating witnesses they
have this epic case most expensive case
biggest cocaine case in federal
government history the jury goes out
comes back not guilty not guilty not
guilty not guilty not guilty everybody
in town knew who these guys were and
what they were doing not guilty what
happens not one not two at least three
jurors were paid off the tentacles that
these guys had in the community the
roots they had they could reach out and
touch three jurors and pay them
including the foreman who was a lot it
was a baggage handler at Miami
International Airport
okay baggage supervisor this guy starts
running around with a Rolex a new boat
goes to the Bahamas the feds are like
what the [ __ ] this guy running around
doing over here turns out he got paid by
by by by some by some shady characters
and the next thing you know the US
Attorney the main guy in the Southern
District of Florida
Kendall coffee is his name you see him
sometimes on CNN as a talking head up
London right
this guy is so upset about this win I
mean this lost they don't know that they
got screwed with this jury yet but
literally like the night or two after
the the acquittal he gets so upset he
goes to a club lipstick on South Dixie
let's call it a gentlemen's club shall
we club lipstick all right on us one in
South Miami he uses his company card
which means his US Attorney MX card to
buy a magnum of champagne winds up
getting a private dance and biting the
stripper he is drunk off his ass Egret
bite sir so here's what happens the neck
the next day this US attorney his dad
goes to the club and wants to pay cash
to buy the receipt that meaning like
credit the card back and let me pay you
cash for and I like get out of here with
that and the bouncer who it turns out is
the boyfriend of the stripper that he
bet sees this this guy coming in trying
to buy the receipt thinking who is this
like what's going on here is this some
VIP what he reports it next thing you
know guy resigns like this is some
classic Carol Hayase and only in Miami
kind of [ __ ] guy resigns guys whole
career is over and the next thing you
know you find out they bought off the
jury there were witnesses that were
murdered there was an attorney that was
murdered and they start putting together
the second case the second round that's
why this thing is six hours it's just
like it's just and it and it helped to
it basically a subsidized the entire
criminal defense bar of Miami because
there were so many defendants and so
many cooperating witnesses and so many
they called him satellite cases and
there was murder cases and there was
money laundering cases and there was
jury tampering cases that so every every
attorney almost in every attorney in
Miami at that time had some case or had
it was making a living in some way or
another off of a william Salle case or
satellite case I don't think there's
ever been maybe the Watergate scandal in
DC where more attorneys were involved
with more defendants that it just seemed
to to literally finance the whole
criminal defense bar in one town and and
here like you go where were 20 years
later from the from the second case in
the last case and there's still lawyers
working in various cases just this week
there was a fugitive in the case they
call him the media's dubbed them the
last of
cocaine Cowboys this is Gustavo Falcone
Willy Falcone's brother this guy on the
show all their buddies I mean everybody
they know is getting subpoenaed into a
grand jury so they know there's gonna be
some secret you know some sealed
indictment and you know you know what's
happening you know him you can see the
writing on the wall so this guy his wife
his son and his daughter
they were like 9 and 10 years old about
that they disappear just before the
indictments come down and everybody gets
raided and busted and and shackled this
guy disappears with his wife and two
children little children and they're
gone for 26 years remarkable I mean they
just disappeared for 26 years guy was on
America's Most Wanted three times he was
he with he and Osama bin Laden were on
on the FBI top ten list at various times
together just last year the guy is
living in a rental house near Epcot in
Orlando Florida Kissimmee Florida guy
gets busted they catch him after 26
years LEM just three days ago he pled
guilty and was sentenced and the judge
said you know I I life on the lam is
tough you know cuz he threw himself on
the mercy of the court he said that was
no kind of life I was in a prison of my
own making for 26 years you know nearly
ruined my children's lives they're in
their 30s now they never got to move out
of the house you know they never got to
go on the grid get driver's license have
a normal life he's like and and the
judge was simply school the judge was
sympathetic and said listen you gotta
you pled guilty you gotta pay a debt to
society I wish I could give you less
time but this is so much cocaine it's
just so much cocaine he repeated it
twice game 11 years game 11 years and
it's a case that keeps going it just
keeps going willie Falcone did 20 years
got out ice took him put him in
immigration prison in Louisiana not to
tell you he's not staying at your hotel
with the good food I'll tell you what
the good eats he's staying at some
immigration some ice hellhole
this was just last year they released
him from prison last year I stuck them
with an immigration hold here's the
thing he's Cuban never became a citizen
US citizen but he's Cuban so the judge
ordered him deported the problem is the
relationship with Cuba
as you know you know there's some
Animists there you know with the Obama
administration you know date on brought
a you know a little more cooperation but
now it's been a little bit of a roll
back and so no one sure if Cuba will
agree to take the guy or not so now he's
in this sort of like purgatory in this
sort of limbo and no one knows what's
gonna happen and where's the other guy
Sal decided to go to trial really pled
the government had a very sophisticated
divide-and-conquer kind of approach to
them they had charged Sal with
money-laundering witness the witness
murders and jury tampering jury bribery
Willie they just charged they only had
enough evidence they felt to prove
money-laundering they didn't have him
they felt on the the jury bribery or the
witness murders so here's the problem
you know how this goes you got two guys
sitting next to each other one
co-defendant charged with murder the
other one not charged with murder you
got to take your chances with these
twelve people who were gonna sort it out
and and you know and and and and try to
distinguish between this guy
so Willie cut his losses pled guilty to
the money-laundering took a 20-year plea
Sal decided to go to trial got acquitted
of the witness murders got acquitted of
the jury bribery and got acquitted of
the cash money laundering he got
convicted of writing eight checks on a
Tel Aviv bank to his attorneys he was
convicted of money laundering for paying
his attorneys with these checks with
these eight checks judge sentenced him
to 200 years in prison so the same stuff
that his partner had pled guilty to got
20 years he pled guilty got 200 years 30
of God they got this thing they call um
acquitted conduct where the judge for
whatever reason is allowed to consider
for the purpose of sentencing acquitted
conduct meaning even though he was
acquitted of the murders the judge for
this for the purpose of sentencing could
consider the other charges that he was
acquitted of which sounds to me like a
quasi constitutionally kind of a thing
it's like ultimately you get 200 years
in prison for eight checks that you
wrote to your
terney you know I mean it's a Ritz it's
like an Al Capone thing you know they
got them but they got them you know
creatively let's shall we say so it's a
crazy story that uh you know we were in
a pitch meeting yesterday and someone
said so when does the story end like
when does it come up to I said April
27th 2018 I'm like it's still going on
as we speak this can like it should end
with us here in the room pitching it to
you you buy it and then they could start
over and rebuild from episode one again
it just goes in a circle you know it's a
crazy story that just keeps going on and
it's a story that if you lived in Miami
grew up in Miami in through the 90s and
the zeroes it was front-page news yeah
it was this was like roj this was a big
this is a big [ __ ] story and this was
the story of the cocaine Cowboys that we
always wanted to tell and never had a
chance to until now and no idea when
it's coming up no idea I mean no no I'm
gonna say I'm gonna I'm gonna say it
definitely 2019 I'm hoping earlier than
lay properly mid so probably about a
year I'd say about a year from now six
hours let it can't let it let it a lot
of show yeah a lot of content yeah
always a pleasure brother always
surprised you're having you're happy you
came to town I miss you you look great
I'm trying
you look great I do I walked in the door
I was like who the hell is that skinny
so sexy son of a [ __ ] over there high
school you look great 60 pounds to lose
all right hopefully hopefully we'll give
it a [ __ ] that all [ __ ] tribe man
but I'm happy you came in and said hello
when I miss you miss you too once home
though opens up I'll be back down there
is that that that's the club yeah well
what that look dead well because it the
hard rock you know shut down and they're
there got it Eddie for everything you
should see they're building this [ __ ]
hotel like a guitar yeah they're like
half way that you can see it from the
Turnpike you're like what that's amazing
yeah I mean the thing looks ridiculous
into building a [ __ ] Chevy really all
right are only 21 or something I don't
know it's such a bummer now we got to
schlep up the Palm Beach to the improv
and there is no comedy club and there's
there's there's cool rooms there's
little venues but there is no comedy
club right now basically and you know in
several counties there's one in Boca I
think they got going on its but yeah I
got to go to Palm Beach you know other
Palm Beach yeah you think you should
come down you do Shirley's there's this
little great little bar and Winwood gram
um it's amazing just it's just words on
the wall right in Wynwood you know it's
called Gramps Valentine I am Oh downtown
Miami is like I mean it's like ten
blocks blocks north to downtown miami
right like 23rd Street 24th Street and
uh a few weeks before Hannibal Buress
went to Philly and you know and and made
some some cell phone recorded remarks
about the one dr. Cosby he was in the
room at Shirley's trying out that
material and I swear to God
you know I'm a comedy group yeah I'm at
the Jenner comedy fan and I watch Carlin
bomb in [ __ ] Vegas in 2000-2001 it was
crazy I mean I you know I love comedy
and I'm sitting there and Hannibal's
starts riffing on Cosby doing the same
[ __ ] he wound up doing weeks later in
Philly and my buddy Adam and I who owns
the bar were sitting there packed house
because Hannibal pops you know out of
nowhere shows up we just tweet about it
and boom the place is [ __ ] slammed
right great room little room and he's he
starts doing this cosmic dead silence in
the audience because nobody knows what
the hell he's talking about
I lived out here in the 90s his
reputation was very well-known out here
no one knew about you know say the
quaaludes or whatever the roofie
business or whatever it was but
everybody knew the guy was alleged like
it was very well and if I knew about it
as a kid in LA and the 90s and everybody
everybody knew like people with I heard
stories from actresses and people I
heard stories all the time about Cosby
so I knew all about it I had known about
the accusers in the past and everything
Adam and I are hysterically laughing we
think this is brilliant right and nobody
in the audience cuz we're all a bunch of
kids you know they don't know what the
hell he's talking about you know and we
were the only two [ __ ] laughing
I Hannibal kind of looked at as a nodded
at us because we were the only people
laughing later we're at the bar it's a
crazy night by the way there's a picture
of me Adam Hannibal Buress and Phil
Collins at this club that's how crazy
and Miami this [ __ ] is right it's like I
could feel it coming in the air tonight
baby
so this how so I'm at the bar and I'm
this drunk [ __ ] now you know hanging
on Hannibal going I just want to tell
you that Cosby [ __ ]
is so brilliant I'm like never stop
doing that because it's not only funny
it's true it's important it's like my
twitter feed it's like it's like it's
important like people got to know about
this cuz you can see from the crowd's
reaction nobody knows about this I'm
like you gotta calm that [ __ ] like
you're you keep doing what you're doing
and I'm like it's I'm telling like this
isn't put it's funny but it's important
people gotta you gotta spread the word
he's looking at me like this get get
away from you drunk smoke you know like
I'll be damned not two weeks later not
two weeks later I call up Adam I'm like
you see this [ __ ] this video like that
was the [ __ ] - Hannibal was trying out
here I told him you better keep doing
that [ __ ] I'm like you listen to me I
know it's crazy you yeah they went Cosby
got convicted I was like this is [ __ ]
crazy this is really crazy
they all know now new NBC know
they all know for you they might listen
I knew it I knew I had that I know I was
12 years old with your years old they
[ __ ] ya know they know they dead greasy
[ __ ] pedophile cogsa a you know
an NBC NBC stood for network of Bill
Cosby for awhile I mean he built he
helped build that house with Garson
there was a few guys you know in that in
that era yanked off his reruns oh yeah
sure everybody's [ __ ] done it's a
bummer if you're an actor on that show
used to get you know those residuals
yeah I feel bad I feel bad for those
you're done yeah what are you gonna do
blue apron is deleting milk Keith's
delivery service in the u.s. oh how many
people know what we do many don't know
about the types of meals you eat when
you cook with blue apron you just not
having burgers for dinner license
schmuck you making short rib burgers
with hoppy cheddar sauce on a pretzel
bun
you're preparing seared steaks with a
time pan sauce with mashed potatoes
green beans and crispy shallots oh my
god oh and all under 45 minutes without
a trip to the grocery store okay
that's what blue apron does blue apron
achieves this by achieve this by
supporting a more sustainable food
system setting the highest standards for
ingredients and building a community of
home chef now blue apron offers three
meal plans to person family meal plan
and a wine
plan all right but no the most important
thing in my blue apron is ladies like we
said the recipes they deliver fresh
proportional ingredients step-by-step
recipes right to your door that can be
cooked in under 45 minutes the menu
changes every week based on what's in
season and what's designed by blue
aprons is in-house chefs
okay blue apron office 12 new recipes
each month customers can pick two three
or four recipes based on what it says
schedule boy pan also only sends non GMO
ingredients and meat with no other
hormones you can't beat that
so what I'm gonna do is this check out
this week's menu all right like I told
you check this out chicken Tinga
tostadas with avocado and refried beans
I write roast pork and salsa verde with
sauteed vegetables then in parenthesis
it says Florence Italy if i'm santi you
could be in Ohio in what the Florence
Italy who's bugging you and you don't
have to buy like not just really quick
they send you only exactly what you need
every time I go to the grocery store you
end up having all this extra stuff that
you don't need ya waste your aprons send
it to the dot tip top but go beef and
rice ball with short bald eggs roasted
and a beautiful piece of broccoli beef
empanadas with roasted sweet zucchini
potatoes listen the list goes on and on
what I'm gonna tell you is this do me a
favor go check out the menu again see
what you like what you don't like and
get your first three meals for free
oh boy up in doc times last Joey that's
free slash gratis free blue apron a way
better a better way to cook all right
number two you join in jiu-jitsu you
don't know what to do Joey I don't know
what you're a fat [ __ ] you need a ghee
that's gonna cover that fat [ __ ] we
gotta go see Swan the [ __ ] curtain
make it make your [ __ ] gate you gotta
see the size of my gig it's [ __ ] huge
the pants were eight [ __ ] pounds so
what you got to do is you want to like
key that's durable dependable and it
washes out they put the natural [ __ ]
thing in to keep the [ __ ] and the stinky
people off here and that's the [ __ ]
super Ito ghee from Fuji ok they also
have the Seco they have the plain one
they got the
which is a great guy but any of their
keys I recommend even the $94 purple one
that looks sharper than [ __ ] and it's
lightweight go to Fuji Sports calm right
now press in church but who the [ __ ] is
better than you I'm gonna deliver to
your door like the Savage that you are
you understand me I want to thank my man
Billy Corbin again I also want to thank
people who donate it to Brandi Lynn
Gibbons you guys are helping her out I'm
trying to put together so yeah we can do
a comedy benefit for her but if you
don't know go to my GoFundMe page Brandi
Lynn Gibbons and even if it's two
dollars two [ __ ] dollars you did
something you made somebody's day with
two [ __ ] dollars who gives a [ __ ] you
don't need to be a big shot one more
time blue apron one more time Fuji
Sports my man Billy Corbin and the
original flying Jew aka the Christ
killer I love you [ __ ] all
right I'll see you next Monday get ready
to rock
Tempe I'll see you tomorrow night you
[ __ ] stay black uncle Joey here
kick that [ __ ] mule leave